all right hi my name is Jess telleth I
work for a company called quanto bein a
little brief background disclaimer not a
computer scientists
I'm professing to talk about Python
today but I'm really a user of Python
I don't usually build stuff other than
analyses and data analysis but I'm going
to talk to you about what I think is a
pretty cool tool that my research team
at quanto peein has built in the last
couple of months for the purpose of
evaluating investing strategies or
automated trading algorithms and these
are tools that are commonly used by a
lot of professional quants or industry
quants and some individual investors and
quants who want to try to look at a
systematic investing strategy and
basically take the data that it outputs
such as returns from stocks that are
bought and sold risk factors and try to
understand from the outside and from the
exhaust data whether a trading algorithm
is is making money has made money in the
past why it made money in the past and
how it's going to make money in the
future so I'm going to assume that this
is obviously expert in Python crowd but
maybe not as much background in finance
but if you do have a background in
finance or quant finance or algorithmic
trading could you raise your hand I'll
get a sense well all right then I take
that back so moving right ahead so I
don't think I should have to sell this
but in a lot of talks that I start start
up and say why use Python for quant
finance I think this is kind of becoming
more and more of a foregone conclusion
there's a lot of obvious great things
about it it's general-purpose it lets us
avoid stringing together lots of sort of
use case specific languages that might
have great features but are frustrating
to have to sort of daisy chain together
or code analyses and recode them in
other languages that are better
depending on whether you have a research
or a production use case it's very easy
to learn even I can learn it I come from
a different research background not
computer science and also there's this
you know incredibly vibrant and rapidly
expanding ecosystem of tools that we get
to leverage if we work in Python this is
you know just a cross-section really of
those tools
and the the sort of concept of this one
right is sort of a stack from building
from just the the Python language at the
bottom up to sort of higher and higher
level packages so you know at a
relatively low level you have packages
like ipython which we also leverage and
numpy but as you build up you know
pandas was a library written by Wes
McKinney who I understand unfortunately
not going to make it this afternoon but
what was sort of one of the first
libraries that got written in Python
that really allowed us lazy MATLAB and
our data scientists to use Python right
so we want to work with data frames
right I just have explained to computer
scientists so many times I just want
rows and columns I basically wanted to
be like Excel except I want it to be
fast and I don't want it to be like
excelling that it's going to break so
but otherwise right I want in quant
finance land a lot of times quants think
in terms of you know every row might be
a stock so for every stock you might
have a bunch of dates and then every
column might be a different field of
data so you might care for a stock about
what its price is you might also care
what its forward p/e is Masel care what
its trailing p/e is once you have this
big huge matrix of data then you can
start to do analyses and try to
understand if you have signals in your
data so there's this awesome stack of
tools that we get to use if we use
Python when quanto bian began in 2011 it
was a project started in john Fawcett's
shed behind his house until it got too
cold but basically he decided that he
wanted to write a back tester that would
allow quants to back test trading
strategies and that was something that
when he met quants he realized that
everybody in the quant field was writing
their own back tester this was a great
opportunity to write a piece of software
there's no really great reason to
reinvent the wheel every time a quant
goes from one job to another though
they're not allowed to bring the code
with them so this seemed like a
fantastic spot to create sort of a
single open source library so that was
in 2012 now a couple years later we have
come a long way so quant opions gone
from faucet shed to a floor of a
building in downtown Crossing we've got
38 employees currently who are mostly
engineers but what we're doing is
sourcing algorithm
from our community so we have a website
we let you know anybody who has some
Python programming ability or the
interest in learning come onto our
website and have access to data right
these trading algorithms and now we're
in the position of wanting to evaluate
those trading algorithms and actually
put real money behind them and so to do
that we realized that we were writing
starting to write a bunch of internal
software that wasn't part of our product
and our platform to evaluate trading
algorithms and we realized that you know
that would be something that would be
really useful
externally so we put together this
library and we open sourced it I think
around the end of this summer so pi
folio is a state of the art and changing
like daily and weekly and in its infancy
but I'm reasonably active so far already
community and really the idea again is
this is a set of analytics that is
designed to analyze a portfolio with
respect to returns and risk
characteristics and there's a lot of
exciting things we want to do with it
and I'm going to show you where we've
started so it's open source it's free
it's under the Apache v2 license I have
no idea what that means
again I just use open source software I
don't write it but if you want to use it
I think that means it's easy for you to
use it you can use it in a standalone
basis so it's self-contained you can use
it with zip line zip line is the open
source back tester that I mentioned or
you can use it on our website on quanto
peein and we also have a hosted research
environment that's ipython based and
finally we did I don't know if we did or
cited did but there's a way to use it
with a pack this Python lesions library
as well he's been some pretty cool stuff
so if you want to use pipe folio in a
standalone manner this is all you have
to do you use anaconda and you just
import it to your project pretty simple
and what it's going to give you access
to a sort of mainly is this really nice
big set of visualization so you're going
to hand in a pretty consistent pretty
simple set of data might be something as
simple as just a time series of returns
even for example for like a mutual fund
you might be interested in the two ways
of thinking about what you data you hand
in to pi folio are you can either hand
in
earns based data only and then you're
kind of limited to returns based
analyses things that say hey what's the
volatility been what's the time series
correlation with other assets maybe in
the marketplace then or you can hand in
both returns data and position level
data so if you're handing in the data
about what transactions and buys and
sells you made stocks you held then
there's a richer set of outputs you can
get so some of the plots that you can
see that are sort of miniaturized but
I'll go through these a little more
things like the equity curve so this
green line is you know this is some
magical trading strategy that just only
makes money every day that's exactly
what we're looking for perfect we've got
a bunch of rolling statistics so it
turns out in quant land that it's really
always interesting not only to come up
with a single estimate of something like
the volatility of your data or the risk
adjusted returns of your data but
unfortunately for quants quant finance
is a very non stationary world and so
you're often wanting to look at rolling
indicators over time that say hey over
the last six months what has been my
average risk adjusted return because
everything in quant world parameters or
values that you estimate based on data
you'll see how you'll get to a little
bit later that there's a lot where
you're interested not only in looking at
you know we don't show there's a summary
table but so not only rolling statistics
but also distributions of statistics
distributions of data that you're
getting out of your algorithm because
you're always limited by the number of
data points and the number of
observations you make just like anywhere
in data science and so we've got some
tools that try to help you think about
that all right so once you have so
here's an example if you're only going
to pass returns into a function so if
you've just got a series of stock
returns you can hand those in to this
function to create a tear sheet and this
is that summary table that I mentioned
so the common things that are sort of
the parameters that might define any
back test so you've got a trading
strategy right it's going to do
something but actually really it matters
a lot sort of when you ask it to operate
and at what sort of inception criteria
so this trading strategy was asked to
run from March or so I'm a first May
21st 2012 to 1028
2015 so that's 41 months of backtest if
I hand it in another piece of data which
was when the strategy went out-of-sample
or moved into live trading I would have
the ability to create statistics that
break apart two regimes in-sample and
out-of-sample and you can actually use
that I think to create sort of a regime
study yourself if you wanted to say okay
I have a set of data that I care about
but it's actually three subsets of data
that I want to look at broken out
different ways so right here I just have
one summary set of data
the kinds of summary statistics we like
to look at for quant strategies are
things like what was the annual return
so on average this strategy made 38
percent a year well that sounds great
well its annual volatility was 44
percent a year that doesn't sound quite
as great that would've been a little bit
of a wild ride certainly some some years
so quants look a lot at this Sharpe
ratio right that's just basically a
measure of your risk adjusted returns
the returns over that volatility so what
you'd like to have is that number very
high that's very hard to do mostly
returns come at the cost of risk that's
assumed and risk mostly in the market is
experienced by the stocks going up as
well as down so a Sharpe ratio of one or
near one two to three that's a great
Sharpe ratio strategy for something that
is not sort of like a high-frequency
strategy if you get into very very fast
trading strategies that are really based
on sort of very very small differences
in moving averages you can find
strategies that get into very very high
Sharpe ratios so if you see a strategy
and someone tries to explain to you oh
yeah I know this one's way better this
is a Sharpe ratio of like five or six or
ten that tends to be something that
again has a very limited set of
parameters of where it can actually make
that Sharpe ratio and probably very
small capacity so this looks pretty
reasonable we have a bunch of other
measures I'll also point out we have an
alpha and beta estimate so I think you
have to hand in a benchmark although I
don't see where we're doing it here gift
a hand in the benchmark anyway you don't
have to it just goes and pick something
okay he's one of the guys that actually
did the actual work back there so so the
concept of beta is really important to
us in our workflow beta basically means
what is your correlation
the broad market index you can have a
correlation to any risk factor any
market index for us our platform right
now supports only trading US equities
and so what that means is the most
common thing that strategies that people
in the community come up with are things
that trade sort of it's very hard to not
very hard but it's very easy to pick
things that trade with the market so if
you do something like say hey I know
what I'm going to do I'm going to find a
couple levered ETFs and I'm going to
basically buy the celebrity TF when it's
making some money and hope it's going to
make more money you can achieve really
great returns but you're going to have a
lot of risk so we like to look at this
beta value a beta of 1 means you're
perfectly correlated with the market it
means that if the S&P 500 goes up by 1%
in a given day your algorithm is very
likely to go up by 1% in a given day if
your beta gets above 1 that means you're
over correcting but still correlated so
a beta of 2 if the market takes a dip of
2% tomorrow you're probably gonna lose
4% tomorrow so we're actually us we're
actually looking to see this number get
towards zero so that's why we have it up
in this test summary table we can also
look at when we lost money historically
so a lot of times you look or you know
people will look at the equity curve
like I showed you and we can skip ahead
and look at a nice equity curve here and
there you know humans are great at
recognizing patterns so they'll say well
this looks awesome I lived on that green
line and I ended up way up and to the
right from where I was right so that's
great but what you don't notice by eye
or or doesn't jump out at you kind of at
first is well what were my draw downs so
as I like live through that
rollercoaster ride up that green line
how many times had I lost money and and
how long was it when I had lost money
until I made back past my previous peak
so that's what this worst drawdown
periods is it shows you your 5 worst
draw downs how big they were so 47%
that's like a really not a good drawdown
you wouldn't be able to put like a
reasonable amount of capital behind this
show this to someone who's in industry
and they'd say ok you know who knows
what it is you're doing but you know
this is basically just looks like it's
following the market and it shows you
your peak date your valley date when you
recover it and then how long it was so
you can also see that not only did you
suffer
our time period when you've lost about
half of your money but you took you
about 300 days to get back above your
peak so you can sort of picture yourself
living through like that 200s day
imagine if you knew you had like 100
more days before you're even going to
break even from this trading strategy
okay so it shows you kind of highlight
some of the risks so this is just
looking at the returns to your strategy
versus any benchmark you want to pass in
I've got the S&P 500 and then the second
plot is a volatility adjusted picture of
that then I mentioned that we care about
this beta or this correlation to the
market and I showed you in that summary
table this strategy had a beta of about
1 ok so great that dashed blue line in
the top plot is at about 1 but the other
thing you can see is like Oh interesting
there were times when this strategy had
a beta or you know a trailing six or
12-month correlation that was actually
quite below one at the beginning of the
backtest and at times it actually had a
beta that was about two so you can also
sort of get a sense of these estimates
or these parameters that I care about
how consistent are they over time
if you see parameters that you care
about changing a lot over time that can
be okay right but you want to understand
why because now it means that when you
just do shorthand and look at one
summary number it might not capture
what's happening that much so this is
that estimate of rolling Sharpe ratio
right like okay it looks good we said
it's bits as well it looks okay right
it's around one but okay yeah you also
realize there's times where you lived
well below that line of one so you're
aware of that and then this last plot is
kind of cool so I mentioned that you can
have a beta which is just a sort of a
word in this case domain-specific word
for a correlation so you can have a
correlation to the sp500 right but you
can have a time series correlation to
any other time series you want right
like the phase of the moon or you know
the tides coming in and out crop
rotations well it turns out there are
three really common risk factors that
quants look at these are very basic ones
that you can just download from a
professor's website and they're
basically looking at what's your
correlation with a strategy that just by
small cap stocks and sells large cap
stocks so it turns out they're sort of
that's known risk factor out there that
you know you're taking on risk by buying
small cap stocks right so there are
smaller companies some incident that
happens to them can make a bigger
difference to them maybe there maybe
there they're more likely to go up
they're more likely to go down so small
cap - - large cap high-growth companies
- low growth companies and then momentum
so momentum is saying what about stocks
that have gone up a lot in the past
versus those that have gone down and so
these factors are created by building
synthetic or portfolios of stocks that
are pretending that your strategy was
doing one of those things specifically
and then we look and say okay for this
trading algorithm that either I wrote or
someone else wrote I'm trying to
evaluate how much is it actually making
money probably because of these factors
so with this one you can see okay Wow
like it's actually kind of wandering in
and out of being pretty highly
correlated with some of those factors so
again something to be aware of maybe I
understand and this with this strategy
I'm okay with that I want to take those
risk factors on a pure kind of view here
like a pure quant or pure alpha strategy
really you'd be looking for the residual
or the alpha left after you took out any
returns explained by those other risk
factors so ideally we're looking for
strategies where when we look at that
famine
exposure plot you've got these three
lines really tight around zero in our
particular use case this is just the
visualizations that go along with that
drawdown plot so you can see that that
big really long drawdown that happened
from when you first invested right so
you're like this seems like a great idea
invest my money in this strategy 300
days later do you think you still have
you know your your brokerage account
invested in that strategy probably not
but moving on so this plot is getting at
you know a lot of times you are looking
again at this equity curve and it can be
very misleading because depending on how
you invest your strategy you might be
reinvesting profits over time and so
it's difficult to sort of see across a
time series that that goes maybe ten or
twelve years out in time like where did
I really make and lose money so here
you're going to look at what were the
monthly returns to my strategy by year
and by month and these plots I think
we're all like built in
some cool library that we use that was
built in you guys probably know better
than I do
so this was really easy to create write
win which is awesome we have the returns
by year and then this one is the
distribution of monthly returns that's
kind of cool because when you let's say
first deploy your strategy and you live
through your first month of trading it
you know what your strategy made that
month right let's say you lost 20% you'd
look back at that plot and you'd say mmm
that feels like a pretty low probability
event given the distribution of the
months that I saw in my back tasks that
should be worrisome so that's a nice
distribution to look at and then these
are showing you with a daily weekly or
monthly view how's that distribution of
returns by quantiles and so you can sort
of see where you're worse outliers and
these plots are kind of all designed to
give you other different slices or ways
of visualizing what happened to your
strategy to hopefully help you notice if
there's something that explains you know
the sort of a warning flag a lot of a
lot of evaluating quant strategies is
looking for you know where it goes wrong
or why it isn't going to work and when
you eliminate all of those things you
get increasing levels of confidence okay
so another interesting aspect that you
can look at with this is your exposure
over time and what I mean by long-short
exposure is so if this strategy just
took a hundred thousand dollars and and
invested it in one single stock you
would see this would be the plot would
just be a green bar with the green line
at one so I would be one hundred percent
in one long position but this strategy
is actually a dollar neutral or a market
neutral strategy and so again you would
have to pass that position information
in to know this but basically what we do
is just aggregate up all the stocks you
held long and all the stocks you held
short and then look at your exposure
over time so this strategy is on average
taking on perhaps a little bit of
leverage but it's basically neutral
where it have a dollar long I have a
dollar short
the way people usually talk about a
strategy like this is you're hedged with
respect to the market's movements
hopefully right so well you've done
something presumably hopefully in this
algorithm where you've said these Long's
should should make more money their
price should go up more than these
shorts and if you're right about that
then you
don't care what happened to the overall
broad market right so the market can go
up it can go down but if your system of
differentiating or betting that your
lungs are better than your shorts on a
relative basis if that wins then you
make money that's the idea this is a
plot just looking at exposure to sectors
over time so if you have a strategy that
holds a lot of stocks you can look at
your positions over time but that can
become really complicated so all stocks
live in some sector they can fall into
some category like an energy stock or a
healthcare stock and these are
categorised by a couple of different
data vendors in the market and I think
we are looking at Morningstar asset
classifications and that's because the
Morningstar corporate fundamentals data
is what we have integrated into our
production platform but there are a
bunch of different sector identifiers
like sort of data vendors so this is
just going to be a plot where you can
look and say okay if I consistently had
a much higher exposure to one single
sector than any other then I would know
something more now right about this
strategy okay the strategy is making
money because it's actually only
dripping energy stocks right that'd be
something I'd want to be aware of and
then underneath I'm just looking at how
many stocks do I hold in my portfolio so
this strategy holds about 50 stocks
that's a reasonably high number of
individual stocks for somebody who's an
individual investor right if you think
about what you're going to be paying to
buy and sell each of these stocks
especially you're going to be short half
of these stocks you're going to be
paying interest and fees so this is
starting to get towards the size of a
larger strategy that would probably have
I need to have a bit of capital invested
in it okay so now see how much time do I
have left okay so I'll go through this
analysis quickly if you have a finance
background this will be very simple to
you if not we'll see if you get sort of
what I what I'm driving at but the idea
here is that I don't necessarily know
when I run a simulation how much I'm
going to pay the broker in order to
trade make these trades there are some
cost I can get a really good assumption
about a really good estimate so I happen
to know we're integrated with
interactive brokers and I happen to know
depending on what size account I have
I'm going to pay 0.75 cents a share
anyway up to maybe a little bit higher
than that but let's say that and I know
that if I trade a very small number of
shares the the lowest price they're
going to charge me for a commission is
$1
but what I don't know necessarily is
when I go try to make that trade in the
market that could be any time of day and
I don't know exactly what price I'm
going to get and how close it's going to
be to the price that my quant models
thought so different strategies that
trade stocks at different rates and
different types of stocks different
different names will have different
sensitivity to being wrong about what
that cost estimate is so this is just a
sweep that's looking at what would my
equity curve have looked like if I had a
varying range of slippage assumptions we
don't have zero on here because it tends
to look a little bit crazy if you assume
zero cost of a lot of strategies do very
well and make money but we're going
anywhere from assuming three basis
points to 50 basis points writer or half
of a percent and then for some
strategies you'll look and you'll say oh
wow this strategy once you get to ten or
twelve basis points of slippage it's
going to lose money just basically no
matter what right so that's something
that you know you yourself would want to
be aware of before you actually put your
own money in it and then we want to
think about and this is another way of
looking at that so here I'm looking at
the average annual return that my
strategy is going to make so sort of a
summary stat derived from this chart up
here and then I'm looking at it as I
increase my slippage assumption and so
this strategy is great right even when
I'm assuming a very high well what I'll
tell you is a high degree of slippage
I'm still eating out some gains so I'm
not just like lighting money on fire
many many quant strategies you get out
to that cost assumption they basically
will light money on fire ok so I
mentioned that you can use PI Folio on
its own and and all of that
functionality that I just showed you I
think you can do just on its own you can
also use it in conjunction with the
quanto peon website and the back tester
that we've got and specifically I guess
some of the stuff about looking at
sector exposures right so if you're
using our research platform on quanto
peein then you pass in your returns from
a back test you ran on our platform
it'll go ahead and know
that it can go grab the Morningstar
asset classifications and so you also
have the benefit of having all this meu
Nome in Italy stock pricing data
corporate fundamentals and then we're
adding a bunch more data sources so it
just gives you a lot of stuff that you
can sort of play with and try we've
built in a couple of models for thinking
about transaction costs and slippage and
we also have an API that lets you write
your own custom model I'm curious if
anybody actually has done that it's like
great that we have it but I like it like
data point that says who has done it is
anyone here written a custom transaction
cost or slippage model even anywhere not
just I want to opions oh yeah
all right nice you should put it on
quant OPM okay so that one guy and
there's a whole room so that tells you I
think pretty much everybody uses one of
the built in models that we have because
it gives you a good a good sense of
what's going on so you like I mentioned
there's a way to pull a back test that
you've run on our platform into this
research environment and then run this
tearsheet and hopefully someday soon you
won't even have to do that you'll just
get it as part of the performance report
that you get out when you run a strategy
all right so we'll see how much time I
have to run through but this is sort of
a sneak peek at some exciting stuff that
we're working on some of this is in the
is in the library already but some of it
is actively under development so I sort
of walked through hopefully made clear
this motivation of this use case to
understand like what your strategy is
doing and if it is making money why
that's like something that you care
about the other really big thing you
care about in quant is is it going to
keep making money so let's say you've
satisfied yourself that you know the
equity curve is up into the right you
understand why it's consistent it's high
Sharpe ratio everything is great with
the world right that's in sample data
typically is how we think about that
right that's data that you know
depending on whether you wrote that
algorithm or or you you didn't and
you're looking at it from the outside
like we are
that's all data that that you could have
had access to to overfit not that anyone
would do that but it can have an even by
accident so how do you predict future
results what we've been doing is working
on some modeling techniques using
Bayesian analogy analysis to try to take
uncertainty into account try to
extrapolate from historical levels of
uncertainty and forecast out into the
future and then try to be smart as we're
getting out of say
data coming in about real trading to say
how quickly can we know that this model
indeed performs how we thought it would
or not so a couple high-level things we
use a t-distribution to model the
returns instead of a normal distribution
so stock market returns are not normally
distributed which is a big problem for
doing like a lot of easy statistical
analyses in the field and this relies on
PI MC 3 which is a library written by
Thomas Viki who works on my team and
maybe some of you here might know he's a
huge nerd and he's written a lot of
really cool stuff that we get to use so
this is one of the really cool things
that he wrote that we get to use this
gif is showing you basically starting
off with some very broad estimate about
what my Sharpe ratio might be so this is
all actually thinking about estimating
my remember I told you I'd like a Sharpe
ratio of around 1 this data set is a toy
dataset it has a true Sharpe ratio of
around 0.5 and what this simulation is
showing you is ok well as I draw samples
from a set of data right those samples
come from this T distribution around 0.5
what they can you know be a large range
of numbers right and I don't know what
order I'm going to draw them in so what
we do is we treat that sampling of new
data and we either do that from back
test data to simulate looking into the
future or we have real observations of
new data coming in and what we're doing
is basically adding new and new data to
our analyses to our Bayesian model and
trying to get a better and better
estimate of where we think the Sharpe
ratio is so what's cool about this
analysis is that we can do it and do it
both where we forecast out into the
future and then as we get real data
coming in that's out-of-sample we can
overlay on that blue sort of increasing
confidence cone what's actually
happening and we can see how they line
up so we can make forecasts about how
much out-of-sample data would you need
to have to feel you I've made like the
right model and you had a good
prediction and then as real data comes
in you can sort of say yeah this matches
or this doesn't match so this is an
example of creating one of these
forecasts out into the future there's a
bunch more data I've hidden at the back
right but this is looking at the green
is continued to be in sample data and
now suddenly on this date in October of
2009
this strategy goes out-of-sample and
that's data that I didn't know about
when I built my model so first what we
do is we draw this Bayesian cone out
into the future and that's basically
trying to describe a region that's like
from a ninety-five percent to a five
percent region of probability based on
our simulations and then the dark blue
is like a seventy five to twenty five
percent confidence then I look at my
out-of-sample data and what I want to
see is actually what this one looks like
right I want to see that my
out-of-sample data looks indeed like
what I would have expected it seems like
it's between 25 and 75 percent
probability this is not always the case
as my next example will show you I won't
go through the rest of the plots below
or more nerdy Bayesian distributions so
we don't time for but they're cool so
here's a real-world example this is a
strategy that won the quanto bian open
sidebar we have a paper trading contest
people love to try to gain paper trading
contests they love to try to fit models
to predict the future and get really
good scores this is probably something
I'm not a cowboy user but this is
probably many people have to deal with
in cattle so this green line is we make
you submit to us a two-year back test so
we said okay little suspicious already I
feel I think I was suspicious already
although it does look good this looks
perfect right and then what happens is
we at this point in time this was back
earlier this year we made you pay per
trade it for 30 days only so we wanted
to have a winner of this contest every
month so after 30 days of trading that's
that blue line right there well this
looks great right that's out-of-sample
data it's open to the right it's
consistent with the historical data
right so what could possibly go wrong so
let's zoom in on this time period and
let's say well okay so by our eye and
the amount of data that I showed you
this looks reasonable like at least it's
still up and to the right but where does
it fall within that Bayesian cone
prediction that we would have made now
we didn't actually have this analysis at
this point last year or we would have
said hmm something seems a little bit
off we kind of did say that but in the
interest of falling through and letting
the contest winner get deployed on real
capital so we deployed these algorithms
to $100,000 right so we said okay you
know and then looking back at it right
so this is really on the edge of this
cone this looks like it's probably in a
zone that really you know we should have
sort of almost an
85% confidence level that the strategy
is doing worse at least out-of-sample
even though they're a month and it did
in sample but you know whatever a month
of data is like kind of difficult to
forecast based on so let's see what
actually happens okay so yes actually
what happens is the strategy
almost immediately right so if we zoomed
back in at that cone right we were sort
of like hugging the very edge of that
cone even after 30 days this one's a
little bit offset in time because this
one the cone starts I think actually
when we deployed real money against it
but either way pretty quickly the
strategies real returns falls way
outside of this Bayesian cone so if we
were trading this either ourselves or in
a portfolio where we sort of didn't have
an obligation to keep it running you'd
say like okay well you're fools to keep
this thing running
it's obviously not behaving how it was
and why is that well that's because it's
in sample sharp and it's in sample
statistics did not it all predict the
results that happened out-of-sample and
you know I used that as sort of a funny
example but this happens all the time
and not just with like the users of
quanto bian who are trying to scam the
quanto peon open this happens all the
time in the real world in the industry
even when people are trying really hard
on purpose not to fool themselves
because it's their own money and their
own reputation on the line it's very
difficult to avoid overfitting and so
you can see how having some mechanism
that gives you sort of keeps you honest
and gives you a projection about where
your model thinks your results should
come in can kind of keep you honest
about knowing sort of when you might
have to admit defeat here I think we
could all whether we had a Bayesian
analysis or not you have figured that
out all right so there's a bunch more
stuff that we've written about this
Bayesian cone as we call it our Bayesian
analysis that you can find and I think
these slides and resources will be
available and Thomas who works with me
knows a ton more about this than I do so
you can get ahold of him as well and
then summary on PI folio there's a
webinar where you can basically rehear
me saying this same lecture roughly with
a little bit more quant finance a nerdy
detail that probably needs to be updated
and this is still a very young library
so please contribute and give us bug
submissions and before I wrap up I just
want to plug the other two talks
of my friends and colleagues Andrew
Campbell who will be on stage right
after me and then tomorrow afternoon
Scott Sanderson who's written a really
cool API that is inside of quanto p.m.
for running cross-sectional analyses and
thank you very much for your time okay
so it sounds like we have a couple
minutes for questions so this yep so the
question was does this work for equities
only or what about futures so this being
the library of pi folio you can hand any
returns into it anything you want yep
anytime series you want the quanto bian
platform it has futures coming online
the this quarter there's a couple of
folks beta testing it so if you want to
trade futures on quanto peon email me
and I'll get you access to the beta no
options yet or 9:00 we're not working on
options yet it looks really hard yep
yep
um so sir so I think that what lives in
pi folio is you can pass in a way to
categorize the data it doesn't have
access to those sector codes and I am
like a little bit making this up but I
believe this is how it works that if you
have some like categorization data point
you can pass that in but you wouldn't
have access to these Morningstar asset
classification fields what you can
probably get is a static snapshot of
sectors or classifiers like today and
then you'll like suffer a little bit of
survivorship bias of how that data goes
back into the past any other questions I
will be around after this Gallants or
one more and then I'll be around
afterwards this afternoon if anyone's oh
oh my god it's so horrible the question
was what about stock splits so we I
think currently finally handle like
splits dividends mergers and all those
adjustments I think we handled them
correctly and in two ways so one way
when you're looking back at data in from
the future back and one way when you're
living through the split it's kind of a
hassle yes we do we have done like a
bunch of work to try to handle that
correctly if you try it and it doesn't
work submit another bug to us but we're
yeah we're working on it actively
pipe folio is like one small package
yeah and I don't know how you like break
it apart but zipline the back tester is
another separate package so you can use
them together or on their own
alright thank you
you